así después regalado Manuel al ministro
del interior quien dio a conocer que
Francia finalmente daba su luz verde
para que este barco pueda llegar a
costas francesas pero no sin tener
palabras bastante fuertes en contra del
gobierno italiano calificándolo de falta
de falto de humanidad y de una posición
completamente incomprensible que va en
contra en realidad de las
reglamentaciones que hay en Europa es
decir que un barco como este en este en
este caso con migrantes Pues debe poder
llegar al puerto más cercano Y en este
caso se trataba de llegar a un puerto
italiano porque estaba en aguas
territoriales de Italia además de esto
también dijo que había una posibilidad
de que Francia acogiera unos 3.500
migrantes que están actualmente en
Italia pero que esto queda suspendido
hasta nueva orden en todo caso este este
barco el Ocean baking en donde haya
guarda unos 324 migrantes Debe llegar
este viernes aquí a París a pesar de que
ya se supo un poco más temprano el día
de hoy que hay unos tres de estos mi que
fueron de hecho evacuados de urgencia
porque se encuentran en muy malas muy
malas situaciones de salud y por ahora
pues esto también muestra que digamos
esa tranquilidad esa amistad que había
entre Francia e Italia pues queda rota
sobre todo ahora con este nuevo gobierno
de extrema derecha de Georgia